corporate media failed us so badly
during the 2016 election and yeah I've
been having like many of you probably
have the political conversations around
Thanksgiving not only with a family and
friends but also just overhearing a lot
of political conversations you know
Wednesday night before Thanksgiving like
a very big bar night I don't know if
that's a nationwide thing but where I
grew up in in Northampton Massachusetts
like a major bar night and I heard so
many political conversations some of
which were good conversations and some
of which were really really horrifying
that these views can exist in
Massachusetts but needless to say
corporate media really failed us during
the 2016 election and the david pakman
show in partnership with some other
independent progressive shows we're
going to be launching a major fundraiser
soon sooner than later the exact date
has not yet been determined and we are
going to be raising money not only to
continue expanding the reach of
independent media but also to do more
than just reporting news we are going to
be creating the position of progressive
engagement coordinator and this is going
to allow shows like ours but also other
shows that we will be teaming up with to
actually say hey here's a specific
example of an election or a project that
if we all work together we can actually
get things done maybe it will be an
issue where my audience and the
audiences of other progressive shows
need to get on the phone and call their
elected officials which by the way does
make a difference most people will never
do it but it does make a difference
maybe here's a very strategic in key
campaign that we should all donate to
because of the huge impact it might have
in the house of representatives are in
the senator a gubernatorial race in a
state that had an outgoing read a
Republican governor but we could maybe
turn the state blue these are the types
of conversations that progressives have
to be having and by the way everybody's
got a vote and that was one of the
biggest problems of the 2016 election
and that's also something that the
progressive engagement coordinator will
be working on so that's just one of the
things that this fundraiser will bring
and we'll announce that soon in the
meantime please sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership due
to popular demand I've kept this coupon
code I voted 17 active and that gets you
a forty percent discount off of
membership and I really do hope you'll
take advantage of it at david pakman.com
slash membership again that coupon code
is i voted 17 all one word